grall qui est à côté de vous depuis
quelques temps depuis qu'elle a quitté
france télé elle est libérée des livres
à leur image la fille danielle moreau
commence quand même à gagner la coupe en
revanche elle est allée nickel ça bouge
pas voilà le vrai bien ordre de faire la
même chose un peu mieux ces méfaits là
ne changeait rien même pas que le
coiffeur pas
c'est pas bon ça allait lui faire un
bisou déjeuner ensemble
évidemment ça heureusement une pelle le
problème avec bernard c'est la
gourmandise est allé d'abord premier
rang premièrement vous étiez consentants
que j'avais dit oui j'ai pas trop le
temps pour afficher en fait du temps on
se connaît ouais j'avais un peu de monde
[Rires]
magali qui est complètement choqué vague
annie bernard va enfin réaliser son rêve
voilà franchement notre bnf valoir
depuis quelle date ce fait galocher
provoquer
[Applaudissements]
par la parole du joueur sur ce fait vous
dire j'attends la promo de papa ou maman
et si c'est bien d'accord normal alors
je vais je vais faire une promo
[Applaudissements]